I was curious what you were like as a  kid do you have Barbies did you play  Barbies anything conventional like that  a lot of Barbies um I was I was  fascinated with murder as a child  there's no transition there yes I was  mom I had Barbies and murder no I you  know I would so I would create Barbie  murder mysteries and you know one Barbie  would die and the rest of the Barbies  would have to figure out who the killer  was  it was usually peaches and cream  [ __ ] yeah that kind I don't know is that  a kind of Barbie yeah she's like a  southern belle Barbie and you know what  you gotta gotta keep your eye on old  peaches were these yeah were they were  they just like out with a ritualistic  murders was it get it how freaky did it  get it well my mom doesn't know this so  please don't tell her there was a weird  sexual component yeah yeah old peaches  yeah there I had like a Barbie  whorehouse  [Laughter]  [Applause]  actually you know you can still find  those on eBay